and so tonight it's all about
celebrating women can you finish this
sentence for me the best thing about
being a woman is to people use me out to
this really fast the best thing about
being a woman is all the other great
women that I'm associated with exactly
and it's been an incredible a couple of
years for you are you now sick of people
asking whether you've come of age yeah I
guess so and also let's see any way you
can describe a lot of films that you're
in when you're a teenager it's like a
coming-of-age story because of course at
this age you are coming of age so I mean
I don't know if I'm sick of it but yeah
it's getting a little a little tiring
and an awards event like this if you see
someone that you're not really quite
sure if you've been introduced to them
before how do you star that out I
usually I I don't know I just smile and
and I never know how to sign off like
you know when you leave and you say are
nice to meet you or nice to see you I
never know what to say so I just do a
little mumble of the two and get a nice
ending you and then like give him a hug
in a little way I don't think I have it
down just yet but that's my little well
it'll go to and lastly can you talk me
through your outfit this evening you
look beautiful my outfit is Ashish I
don't know this is Kate Spade and I
always use Kate Spade bags because
they're sick and I think it ties
together my outfit perfectly
I mean enjoy your evening